claude blanchemaison merci d'apporter
votre éclairage en direct sur rt france
alors huitième séance de négociations
aujourd'hui entre londres et bruxelles
les discussions piétinent
pourquoi cela coince comme ça à claude
blanche maison qu'est ce qui bloque je
crois que en effet la tension monte vous
avez raison de souligner mais je
voudrais indiquer que l'année dernière à
la même époque nous étions à peu près
dans la même situation
nous négocions à cette époque là le
premier traité sur excite celui qui
organisait la sortie politique du
royaume uni de l'union européenne et
beaucoup pensé qu'on allait vers un new
deal c'est à dire que cette sortie se
passerait dans le plus grand désordre
est en réalité à la mi-octobre au
conseil européen
boris johnson et les dirigeants du
conseil européen sont parvenus à un
accord
le traité a été ratifié par tout le
monde et le royaume uni est sorti
politiquement de l'union européenne le
31 janvier dernier avec dans ce traité
la mention d'une transition jusqu'à la
fin de l'année avec une manière alors
aujourd'hui on négocie le deuxième
traité sur le rexy il se trouve qu'il ya
une considérations de politique
intérieure britannique qui joue la même
manière que l'année dernière c'est que
au début octobre il y à un congrès du
parti conservateur britannique et que
boris johnson veut apparaître cette
année encore plus que l'année dernière
comme celui qui a largué les amarres du
royaume uni par rapport à l'union
européenne et par conséquent et il n'est
pas question qu'ils fassent de compromis
avant ce conseil européen
peut-être après non plus d'ailleurs en
tout cas avant ce concert avance ce
congrès du parti du parti du parti
conservateur et il est obligé de se
montrer assez dur avec l'union
européenne puisque c'est là dessus qu'il
a été élu alors bien sûr les sujets sont
beaucoup plus difficile que l'année
dernière
il n'est pas sûr que le miracle se
produise au conseil européen du 15
octobre ou le chaos horizon que s'est
fixés boris johnson et que se fixe
d'ailleurs aussi les dirigeants
européens parce que il ya des sujets
beaucoup plus compliqué comme je viens
de le dire le royaume uni n'acceptera
pas un droit de suite de l'union
européenne sur les conditions de
concurrence or l'union européenne ne
peut pas accepter le libre accès des
produits britanniques sur son marché
si elle ne peut pas contrôler les
conditions de concurrence et notamment
contrôler que la politique de subvention
des entreprises est conforme aux règles
communautaires et se contrôler
boris johnson ne l'acceptera pas donc
probablement en effet il n'y aura pas
d'accord de libre échange sur la pêche
évidemment le sujet se présente aussi
comme une confrontation puisque l'union
européenne demandent un accès identique
pour tous ces pêcheurs dans les eaux
britanniques et que le gouvernement
britannique voudrait augmenter la
possibilité de prise par ces pêcheurs de
maquiller par de la multiplier par deux
ou par trois il ya donc là un
antagonisme qui fait que les choses sont
actuellement bloqués et que tout le
monde dans le fond se donnent rendez
vous au 15 octobre
sur quoi également vous parliez de la
pêche est ce qu'il y a
d'autres avancées dans les négociations
auxquelles on pourrait s'attendre après
ce moment nationale dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure c'est à dire pas de
concession britannique avant le parti du
congrès du parti conservateur vous nous
expliquer oui sur la pêche la la
l'affrontement est évidemment totale
mais c'est un sujet sur lequel on on
peut imaginer de négocier puisqu'il
s'agit d'une variable quantitative et
par conséquent les deux côtés si
politiquement le ils le décident peuvent
négocier et il est possible que cela se
produise en effet et que les
britanniques finissent par accepter un
certain accès d'épaisseur de l'union
européenne
huit pays sont concernés notamment la
france dans les eaux territoriales
britanniques
d'autant plus que il sera probablement
impossible d'arriver à un compromis sur
les conditions de concurrence qui
permettrait d'avoir un accord de libre
échange
mais bon les zones sonne dans une
intervention qui l'a fait hier avancé
l'idée qui était qu' il existe est après
tout un accord de coopération entre
l'union européenne et l'australie qui
n'était pas un accord de libre échange
mais qui était un accord qui visait à
faciliter les échanges sans aller
jusqu'aux libre-échange parc par exemple
en reconnaissant mutuellement les
certifications fait par l'autre partie
par l'autre côté de façon à éviter les
doubles certification à la frontière et
à faciliter la fluidité des échanges
mais aussi faciliter l'accès aux marchés
publics mais aussi se mettre d'accord
sur certaines normes techniques et
peut-être que c'est cela que vise boris
johnson
probablement qu'il préférerait avoir un
accord en effet au conseil européen du
15 et du 16 octobre
parce que il a un très grave problème
intérieur à la groie you mean grande
bretagne c'est la position de l'ecosse
le premier ministre de
régional de l'ecosse a prévenu qu' il
réclamerait un nouveau référendum
demandant l'indépendance de l'ecosse
donc bien entendu londres peut s'y
opposer mais cela provoquera de très
vives tensions
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir partagé votre expertise je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales